This lecture is a continued discussion
of latent aspect rating analysis.
Earlier we talked about how to solve
the problem of Lara in two stages when
we first do segmentation of different
aspects and then we use a little
regression model to learn the aspect
ratings and letting the weights.
Now, it's also possible to develop a
unified generative model for solving
this problem, and that is we not only
modeling, we not only model the
generation of overrating based on text,
we also model the generation of text
and so a natural solution would be to
use topic model.
So given an entity, we can assume there
are aspects that are described by word
distributions.
Topics and then we can use a topic
model to model the generation of the
review text.
Our assumed the words in the review
text are drawn from these
distributions.
In the same way as we assumed for a
generative model like PSA.
And then we can then plug in the latent
regression model to use the text to
further predict the
Overall rating and that means we first
predict the aspect rating and then
combine them with aspect weights to
predict the overall rating.
So this would give us a unified
generative model where we model both
the generation of text and the overall
rating condition on text.
So we don't have time to discuss this
model in detail, as in many other cases
in this part of the course where we
discuss the cutting edge topics.
But there is a reference site here
where you can find more details.
So now I'm going to show you some
simple results that you can get by
using this kind of generative models.
First it's about rating decomposition.
So here what you see are the decomposed
ratings for three hotels that have the
same overall rating.
So if you just look at the overall
rating you don't.
You can't really tell much difference
between these hotels, but by
decomposing these ratings into aspect
ratings we can see some hotels have
higher ratings for some.
Dimensions like value, but others might
score better in other dimensions like
location and so this can reveal
detailed opinions at the aspect level.
Now here, the ground truth is shown in the
plans, so this also allows you to see
whether the prediction is accurate.
It's not always accurate, but it's
mostly still reflecting some of the
trends.
The 2nd result is to compare different
reviewers on the same hotel so the
table shows the decompose ratings for
two reviewers about same hotel again
their high level overall ratings are
the same.
So if you just look at the overall
ratings, you don't really get that much
information about the difference
between the two reviews.
But after you decompose the ratings you
can see clearly they have high scores
on different dimensions.
So this shows that the model can reveal
differences in.
Opinions of different reviewers and
such a detailed understanding can help
us understand better about reviews and
also better about their feedback on the
hotel.
This is something very interesting
because this is in some sense some
byproduct in our problem formulation.
We did not really have to do this, but
the design of the generative model has
this component and these are sentiment
waits for words in different aspects.
And you can see the highly weighted
words versus the negatively lower
weighted words here for each of the
four dimensions.
Value, rooms, location and cleanliness.
I added the top words, cleared it,
makes sense, and the bottom words also
makes sense.
So this shows that with this apology,
we can also learn sentiment information
directly from the data.
Now this kind of laxing is very useful
becausw in general a word like long,
let's say, may have different the
sentiment polarities for different
context.
So if I say the battery life of this
laptop is long, then that's positive.
But if I say the rebooting time for the
laptop is long, that's bad, right?
So even for reviews about the same
product laptop, the word long
Is ambiguous, it could mean positive or
could be negative, but this kind of
lexicon that we can learn by using this
kind of generative models can show
whether a word is positive for a
particular aspect, so this is clearly
very useful, and in fact such a lexicon
can be directly used to tag other
reviews about hotels or tag comments
about the hotels in social media like
tweets.
And, what's also interesting that since
this is an almost computer and
supervised, assuming that the reviews
with overall ratings are available, and
then this can allow us to learn from
potentially a large amount of data on
the Internet to reach sentiment
lexicon.
And here are some results to validate
the preference weights.
Remember, the model can infer whether a
reviewer cares more about service or
the price.
Now, how do we know whether the
inferred weights are correct and this
poses a very difficult challenge for
evaluation.
Now here we show some interesting way
of evaluating result. what you here are
the prices of hotels in different
cities, and these are the prices of
hotels that are favored by different
groups of reviews.
The top ten other reviewers with the
highest inferred value to other aspect
ratio.
So for example, value versus location
value versus room etc.
But the top ten are the reviewers that
have the highest ratios by this
measure.
And that means these reviewers tend to
put a lot of weight on value as
compared with other dimensions.
That means they really emphasize on
value.
The bottom ten, on the other hand, are
the reviews that have the lowest ratio.
What does that mean?
Well, that means these reviewers have
put higher weights on other aspects
than value, so those are people that
care about the another dimension and
they didn't care so much about the
value in some sense by this, less
compared with the top ten group.
Now these ratios are computer based on
the inferred weights from the model.
So now you can see the average prices
of hotels are favored by toptenreviews
are indeed and much cheaper than those
that are favored by the bottom 10.
And this provides some
Indirect way of validating the infer
wait.
It just means the weights are not
random and they are actually meaningful
here and in comparison with the average
price in these three cities, you can
actually the top ten tends to have
below average price, whereas the bottom
time where they care a lot about other
things like service or room condition
tend to have hotels that have higher
prices than average.
So with these results we can build a
lot of interesting applications.
For example, direct application would
be the generator rated aspect, the
summary.
An because of the decomposition, we can
now generate the summaries for each
aspect.
The positive sentence is negative
sentences about each aspect.
It's more informative than original
review that has just overall rating and
review test.
Here are also mother results about the
aspects discovered from reviews with
low ratings.
These are MP3 three reviews an these
results show that the model can
discover some interesting aspects
commented on low overall ratings versus
those high overall ratings, and they
care more about the different aspects.
Or they comment more on different
aspects.
So that can help us discover, for
example, consumers trained in
appreciating different features of
product.
For example, one might have discovered
the trend that people tend to like large screens
of cell phones or lightweight of laptop
etc.
And such knowledge can be useful for
manufacturers to design their next
generation of products.
Here are some interesting results on
analyzing users rating behavior.
So what you see is average weights on
different dimensions by different
groups of reviewers.
And on the left side you see the
weights of reviews like the expensive
hotels they give.
The whole expensive hotels five stars
and you can see their average weights
tend to be more focused on service and
that suggests that people might be
expensive hotels because of good
service.
And that's not surprising as also
another way to validate the inferred
weights.
But if you look at the right side where
look at the column of five stars, these
are the reviewers that like the cheaper
hotels and they give cheaper hotels,
five stars as we expected, and they put
more weight on value and that's why
they like the cheaper hotels.
But if you look at the when they didn't
like expensive hotels or cheaper hotels
and you seal it tended to have more
weights on the condition of the room
cleanliness.
So this shows that by using this model
we can infer some information that's
very hard to obtain, even if you read
all the reviews.
Even if you read all the reviews, it's
very hard to infer such preferences or
such emphasis.
So this is a case where text mining
algorithms can go beyond what humans
can do to review interesting patterns
in the data, and this of course can be
very useful.
You can compare different hotels,
compare the opinions from different
consumer groups in different locations,
and of course the model is general.
It can be applied to any reviews with
overall ratings, so this is very useful
technique that can support a lot of
text mining applications.
Finally, there is also some result on
applying this model for personalized
ranking or recommendation of entities.
So because we can infer the reviewers
weights on different dimensions, we can
allow a user to actually say what do
you care about.
So, for example, if a query here that
shows 90% of the way it should be on
value and 10% on others.
So that just means I don't care about
other aspects, I just care about
getting a cheap hotel.
My emphasis is on the value dimension.
Now what we can do is such a query is
that we can use reviewers that we
believe have a similar preference to
recommend the hotels for you.
How can we know that we can infer the
weights of those reviewers on different
aspects?
We can find the reviewers whose weights
or more precise whose inferred
weights or similar to yours and then
use those reviews to recommend the
hotels for you.
And this is what we call a personalized
or rather query specific
recommendation.
The non personalized recommendation
results are shown on the top.
An you can see the top results
generally have much higher price than
the low Group, and that's because when
reviewers cared more about the value as
dictated by this query and they tend to
really have favor low price hotels.
So this is yet another application of
this technique.
And shows that by doing text mining we
can understand the users better.
And once we can end users better, we
can serve these users better.
So to summarize our discussion of
opinion mining in general, this is a
very important topic and with a lot of
applications.
And as a task sentiment analysis can be
usually done by using just text
categorization, but standard techniques
tend not to be enough and so we need to
have enriched feature representation.
And we also need to consider the order
of those categories and we talk about
the ordinal regression.
For solving this problem.
We have also shown that generative
models are powerful for mining latent
user preferences, in particular in the
generating model for letting the rating
regression, we embed some interesting
preference information and sentiment
weights of words in the model.
As a result, we can learn those useful
information when fitting the model to
the data.
Most approaches have been proposed and
evaluated for product reviews, and that
was the cause in such a context of the
opinion holder an opinion target or
clear and they are easy to analyze and
there of course also have a lot of
practical applications, but opinion
mining from news and social media is
also important, but that's more
difficult than analyzing review data,
mainly because the opinion holders
and opinion targets are all.
implicit and so that calls for natural
language processing techniques to
uncover them accurately.
So here are some suggested readings,
the first 2.
are small books that are excellent
reviews of this topic where you can
find a lot of discussion about the
other variations of the problem and
techniques proposal for solving the
problem.
The next two papers are about the
generative models for letting the
aspect rating analysis.
The first one is about solving the
problem using two stages and the second
one is about the unified model where
topic model is integrated with the
regression model.
To solve the problem using a unified
model.